nous accueillons à présent notre invité
jean lain la capelle député européen du
rassemblement national et porte parole
du rassemblement national
venez monsieur la catalyse et
installez-vous genre avec à peine
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être notre
invité ce matin j'en alain capelle
sincèrement est-ce que vous vous
attendiez à un tel score 89 députés cdu
est difficile de chiffrer
nous attendions une bonne performance
oui sentir sur le terrain
en revanche celui et à 577 élections qui
représentait les 500 zones cette
circonscription et c'est très difficile
ce soir une projection simplement
l'impression vous même quand je dis vous
ce sont les cadres du rassemblement
national vous avez été un peu surpris
par par parle encore de ce résultat donc
j'ai plutôt vu surpris moi sommes de
consommateurs à qui nous avions dit que
nous aurions plusieurs dizaines de
députés qui entre à l'assemblée
nationale et ce fut le cas hier ça a été
une victoire historique aux souvent moi
j'y suis depuis 37 ans est donc en effet
en 1986 sous le mode de scrutin était
différent était issu de la
proportionnelle nous n'avions jamais
connu cela c'est une victoire
territoriale votre confrère le disait il
ya quelques instants des faits puisque
nous avons au delà nos zones de force
nous avons réellement quasiment réaliser
des grands chelems dans beaucoup
département lors le var le vaucluse le
pas de calais mais aussi eu leur l'yonne
l'aube ont fait des départements dans
lesquels nous allons pas l'habitude
d'avoir des victoires électorales donc
ce qui veut dire que nous sommes on
réussit ses autres implantations dont on
aura seulement nous sommes le premier
parti de la ruralité avec marine le pen
avait réalisé était arrivé en tête dans
22 villes communes lors d'élections
présidentielles dès lors du premier tour
des châtiments ça nous arrivait en tête
de 11 villes je crois ça semble une
hausse qui démontre que nous sommes le
parti de la france le parti de la
réalité est que nous allons mettre dans
formés grâce aux français que je
remercie d'ailleurs pour nous avoir
accordé leur confiance de nouveau et
hier nous allons incarner le premier
parti d'opposition à la scène nationale
alors justement marine le pen a dit
qu'elle comptait incarner une opposition
ferme mais responsable ça veut dire quoi
concrètement écoutez ça veut dire qu'ils
ne seront pas dans l'idéologie vous êtes
prêts à voter donc tu l ments certaine
mesure
je crois que c'est pour ça que les
français nous ont élus et c'est pour ça
que les français ont dit non à la
majorité actuelle
ou à d'autres d'autres formations
politiques si les républicains aussi les
socialistes ont disparu c'est parce que
pendant des années ils se sont appelés à
voter les uns pour les autres les
français en ont ras le bol de cela
monsieur mélenchon
parce qu'il ya des personnalités encore
locale mais je vous rappellerai quand
même que lors des élections
présidentielles admis pour les 1 et 4 ni
pour les autres c'est ses proches de la
disparition les français en ont marre
des ces petits arrangements et deux de
ses petits calculs quelquefois au
service de quelques sièges ce qu'il
souhaite aujourd'hui c'est qu'on les
défende avec honnêteté et nous serons
donc si les choses vont dans le bon sens
et par exemple sur le pouvoir d'achat si
marine le pen a été la première à mettre
au coeur du projet auquel campagne les
caissons de bois l'achat dès le mois de
septembre d'indécis demain eh bien il
ils retiennent à 109 proposition la
baisse de la tva de 20 à 5 5 % c'est le
pro d'énergie la suppression de la tva
sur quelques produits de première
nécessité sans produit que marine le pen
avait recommandé et si l'indexation des
retraites se fait notamment
comme marine le pen allait proposer
aussi s'il ya une indexation de la
retraite et j'écoutais tout ceci sera
votée nous irons toujours dans le sens
de la défense d'intérêts
texte pouvoir d'achat de la part du
gouvernement vous êtes prêts à voter ces
mesures il ya des choses qui seront bien
en beauté mais nous sommes contre les
sparadraps nous voulons les choses
beaucoup plus profonde que celle là donc
nous avons le projet de loi qui sera
présenté
mais je laisse marine le pen le faire
elle présidera ce groupe là où vous
l'avez compris il est composé de plus
qu'un droit des personnes parce que nous
aurons 4 89 députés du rassemblement
mais aussi des gens comme nicolas dupont
aignan qui le rejoindront mails ménard
je le crois aussi donc c'est un c'est un
groupe qui va dépasser les frontières du
ratio national c'est une bonne chose
écoutez les co2
tout ce qu'ils souhaitent nous rejoindre
qui partagent les valeurs patriotiques
qui sont les autres qui partagent nos
valeurs et bien écoutez oui bien sûr son
sont invités à nous rejoindre pour
former ce grand bloc sociale identitaire
et national est ce que vous réclamez la
démission d'elisabeth bord d'un
changement de premier ministre ce matin
écoutez je vais laisser mes almagro
prendre ses responsabilités mais
le casting je crois me paraît secondaire
ce qui l'a terrassé quel est le projet d
macron palace et un casting à ce que
vous dites il ya une élection hier est
ce que
ça serait entendre le message que de
démissionner les habitants où est ce que
nous ont finalement réalisé votre banque
peut rester parce qu'elle a gagné dans
le calvados et parce que ensemble est
majoritaire à l'assemblée et même ma
grand gagner avec son réseau ciel
légitimement marine le pen ar gouilh 42%
lors de cette action la bible à mâcon
s'est adressé aux français en disant
j'ai entendu mon message il ya un
message quel message a été finalement
entendus ou comment il l'a convertie on
n'a rien vu en deux mois au gouvernement
de rupture il puisque de façon ils ont
tout fait pour la position du
gouvernement regardez maximum de temps
et puis ensuite le le devoir de réserve
avec finalement il a rien de concret n'a
été réalisé mais qu'at-il envoyer comme
message aux français c'est le maintien
de monsieur darmanin et le maintien de
monsieur dupont moretti deux
portefeuilles ou le ou là où le bilan a
été désastreux de portefeuille dont on
sait que les ministres et des mamans des
adversaires politiques tu rassembles
ationale parce que nous n'étions pas sur
la même ligne et en plus de cela la
cerise sur le gâteau il a nommé pape
ndiaye à l'éducation nationale m
l'ambassadeur du gauchisme en france et
je ne vous donnerai pas tout son cv je
crois que ça a été déjà assez décrié la
réponse café et même macron dès
aujourd'hui afin qu'il change
eh bien qu'ils changent et c'est pour ça
que je dis moi c'est pas les bornes je
veux pas j'ai pas les attaques
personnelles et les soirs au casting
que la folle politique d'immigration a
continué est-ce que l'effondrement du
bois là ça va continuer nous venons d'en
parler et skoda les prennent pas ces
grilles des votes il est le ce que l'on
a vu au stade de france le chaos qui a
été l'illustration de la capacité du
gouvernement à maintenir la sécurité en
france est-ce que cela va continuer est
ce que le recul et mocratie parce que là
aussi nous avons hier soir assister à
l'enterrement du mode de scrutin
majoritaire nous avons assisté à
l'enterrement du front républicain c'est
à dire pour vous la leçon à tirer de ces
élections c'est qu'il faut plus que
jamais la proportionnelle il faut
souligner le ca sursaut populaire quand
on l'entend dire j'espère email
maintenant entendu les français
demandée et la proportionnelle
jusque-là tromper dans votre analyse et
ce n'était pas la faute du mode de ce
que non ce n'était que les français ne
voulaient pas de vous à l'assemblée
jusque là je ne crois pas je ne le crois
pas je crois que le mode de scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours étaient là bien
évidemment c'est pour ça que la
suppression la proportionnelle avait été
légalement décision était là pour
empêcher le récent la sonal de la part
des politiques un bon la barre des
parisiens ampleur nationale d'aller
dossier de cg l'assemblée nationale les
français ont dit stop
dans tous les pays d'europe il ya un
mode de scrutin provincial pour les
chaînes étant tous les bruits demander
encore de nous le demander encore bébé
l'amendé en par changer d'avis c'est pas
parce que les français nous ont permis
d'avoir 80 députés avec un mode de
scrutin majoritaire que nous allons
renier je crois que l'arbre nation ale
loi total et le mode de scrutin
provincial et des bas des scrutins
justes maintenant bien que l ma croix
après la gouverner avec une opposition
forte comme celle qui a été hier choisi
par les français et qui le prennent en
compte un certain nombre de nos deux
lots prestement en quelques jours
recommandations en quelques mots le
premier texte porté par le rn sera liée
à la lutte contre l'islamisme a dit
marine le pen qu'est-ce qui contiendra
concrètement ce projet de loi cette
proposition alors marine le pen en effet
s'est exprimé là dessus les quelques
jours le projet d'eau était connue est
la présence du mois d'octobre dernier
donc les projets de loi pour grady
qu'est l'islamisme dans toutes ses
formes avec la suppression la fermeture
des mosquées le radical que l'expulsion
des fichiers étrangers pour islamisme
radical avec l'expulsion des imams
radicaux étrangers avec la suppression
des investissements étrangers avec la
suppression des centres de subventions
également dans les mosquées salafistes
mais tout est parfaitement cousu et
structurée elle a présenté au mois
d'octobre mais ce n'est pas là le seul
projet doit elle l'a dit le projet de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est notre priorité c'est la priorité
du groupe et marine le pen sera amené à
s'exprimer ici de quelques heures
jusqu'à
marine le pen vous l'avez dit elle
prendra la tête de ce groupe qui sera un
renfort est ce qu elle peut rester à la
tête de votre parti mais c'est à elle de
prendre cette décision elle a dit
qu'elle prendra cette décision là à
l'issue donc du scrutin législatif il
vient d'avoir lieu je pense que marine
le pen
conformément à sa première attention je
crois qu'elle quittera la présidence du
mouvement pour se concentrer sur la
présidence de ce groupe 2 89 députés à
l'assemblée nationale et puis ensuite
vous avez dansé d'entre vous vous
demandez des instances une procédure
donc
mais moi je n'ai aucune préférence et je
ne fais aucun souci
sera probablement ou peut-être le succès
c'est en effet au sein des instances
pour cela un congrès qui se réunira
dans un bon état d'esprit le choisiront
oui ou non revendiquez-vous la
présidence de la commission des finances
en vue notamment mais vous savez que
notamment les partis d'opposition nous
avons droit à 7,92 auteurs gative
j'espère que le merci le les conventions
et le droit républicain s'appliqueront
également pour nous merci à vous la
capelle on va
[Musique]